哈囉大家好我是劉曜增醫師
過去我輪班將近十年時間
在這段日子裡我深刻體驗一件事
那就是夜貓子和輪班工作者
更不能停止運動
今天這集我會用我的親身經驗告訴你
為什麼跑步能救你的血糖、睡眠、甚至大腦
有一個非常震撼的實驗
找了一群健康的二十歲大學生
只要求他們做一件事
實驗的三週內
把日常活動降到最低
可以是臥躺、久坐
但不需要完全不動
結果三週後
他們的心肺功能
直接下降了二十六%
而更驚人的是
四十年後
找招集這幾位
已經六十歲的研究對象
再進行測量
發現他們二十歲經過三週後的心肺能力
居然和六十歲時
心肺能力下降的幅度相當
一個二十歲的身體
在短短二十一天內
就因為不動
老化成六十歲的狀態
這證實了一件事
不動
比想像中讓身體更快壞掉
這個我自己很有感
我自己從二十多歲
替代役階段到急診醫師輪班
快十年
一直都有維持跑步的習慣
一週跑三到五次
每次八到十公里
身體狀況和血糖
其實一直都在正常範圍
直到一兩年前
因為工作更忙
壓力更大
同時
也要兼顧家庭
變成一有空
我就只能補眠
而犧牲了運動時間
變成一週不到一次
去年底爬山
我直接嚇到
短短幾個月
活動量下降
我的體力
瞬間回到沒有運動的狀態
去健檢的時候
甚至發現
我的糖化血色素
居然已經到臨界值
等於是糖尿病前期的狀態
這件事我在上支影片有提過
當時其實把我嚇到了
因為我一直覺得年輕無敵
就算輪班工作者的健康風險
本來就比一般人高
但我那麼年輕
代謝這麼好
一定不會有事
卻沒想到
再怎麼新鮮的肝
你這樣一直操
一直做輪班工作
一旦活動量掉下來
原本那些風險
就會被整個放大
甚至還有一個追蹤研究發現
對於剛開始
輪夜班的人
在他們的BMI和血脂
沒有明顯惡化之前
他們的身體活動量
MET 分數
已經顯示下降
這代表
憂鬱情緒 活動量下降
是夜班工作傷害身體的
第一個信號
為什麼呢
因為輪班者的身體
每天都在對抗
日夜節律
日夜節律失調
有多可怕呢
如果你是輪班工作者
相信你身體多少
會有這樣的感受
總是很累卻睡不著
體重莫名其妙增加
腸胃消化不穩定
或者免疫力下降
常常感冒
日夜節律是內建在身體裡面
告訴我們
什麼時候該睡覺
什麼時候該清醒
它影響的是
睡眠
消化
免疫系統等多方面荷爾蒙
如果你的生理時鐘失調
等於它不知道該在什麼時間
釋放恰當的荷爾蒙
體內就會亂掉
所以有很多研究已經證實
長期輪班工作
與心血管疾病
糖尿病
失智症
免疫系統失調等健康風險
高度相關
聽到這裡
你可能會想說
那我是不是補更多眠
吃得更乾淨
就能救回來呢
美國心臟學會研究提醒
光靠這兩點
很難完全修復被打亂的節律
而是要掌握
飲食運動和睡眠的最佳時機
舉例來說
晚餐太晚吃
因為身體在夜晚
處理糖分的能力比較低
如果你太晚吃晚餐
會讓代謝能力在低谷的狀態下
還是要執行消化工作
這樣會增加心血管疾病的風險
第二
晚上做高強度運動
由於人體在準備入睡時
核心體溫需要略下降
才能進入睡眠狀態
但運動後需要相當長的時間
才能讓核心溫度降下來
所以容易影響我們的入睡和睡眠品質
第三
睡眠不規律
不規律的睡眠時間
即使你的睡眠長度夠
還是會影響日夜的節律
進而導致心血管疾病的風險升高
輪班
晝夜顛倒的人
身體其實承受的修復壓力
比你想像中更大
我把你們更該注意的營養重點
整理成一張表
點擊右上方連結
就能領取囉
那如果因為輪班工作
也沒辦法調整時間呢
我們到底可以怎麼做
他提出最有效的方法之一
就是規律運動
這邊文獻沒有指定一定要做哪一種運動
但他強調一件事
晝夜節律混亂
是輪班者最致命的慢性病風險來源
所以你的運動必須做到
保持規律
又能每天做到
那我覺得所有運動裡面
比較容易
強度剛好
同時又不會影響工作表現的
就是 Zone 2 慢跑
Zone 2 的三大優勢有什麼呢
第一
拯救血糖
Zone 2 能改善粒線體功能
提高胰島素敏感性
幫助血糖控制
有效降低
二型糖尿病患者的糖化血色素
平均可以降低0.5到0.7%
也有助於預防心血管疾病
第二
拯救大腦
尤其在中老年族群
長期有氧訓練
能提升腦血流
降低腦血管阻力
增強海馬回功能
改善記憶力
還可以提升腦部的
BDNF濃度
促進神經可塑性
並且減少我們的焦慮 憂鬱的症狀
那對我自己來說
有跑步的那一天
我上班精神超級集中
沒跑步的那一天
我整個人反而就是累
精神不好
第三
拯救睡眠
Zone 2 可以顯著改善睡眠效率
增加慢波睡眠的時長
幫助更快入睡
減少夜間醒來的次數
進而提升主觀睡眠品質
新手怎麼開始
教你最簡單最容易的方式
首先
找到微喘的感覺
Let's go
一般會定義 Zone 2 心率為
最大心率的 64 - 76%
但這只是標準公式之一
我覺得最適合大眾的方式
就是你的體感
就是跑起來
可以講話
但不會太喘
像我現在這個樣子
就是 Zone 2 的感覺
在這邊要提醒大家
同樣的配速
每個人體感不一樣
例如五分速
我的 Zone 2 心率大概是140下左右
跑完我還能上班一整天
但對於新手來說
這個可能會很喘
為什麼會這樣子呢
因為每個人的 Zone 2 心率不一樣
找到適合自己的 Zone 2 最重要
也就是你的體感
第二選擇適合你的地點
我會建議新手挑選家附近公園的跑道
或者是車少空曠的地方
那跑步機呢
也可以
像我之前常常輪班
只能在下午兩、三點最熱時間運動
那這時候我就會選擇跑步機
那它的優點呢
它可以不受天氣 空汙的干擾
也可以適時地補水
但它還是有缺點
像是跑道較軟
它對我們的腿部肌群刺激較少
所以在戶外運動的時候
我們會覺得比較沒力
但如果沒有適合的環境
跑步機還是一個很好的選擇
但我會建議
如果可以的話
還是到戶外路面訓練
可以讓我們的腿部肌群
刺激更完整哦
三、漸進式的保持習慣
如果你沒有運動習慣
那我會建議這樣開始
首先一週運動一到三次
每次二十分鐘就好
可以從快走
慢慢進步到 Zone 2 強度的慢跑
只要隔天起床沒有特別累
代表強度是對的
慢慢地適應之後
我們可以增加運動的時間與次數
就可以囉
最後提醒大家
這份研究還追蹤了
已經停止上夜班的人
結果發現
即使不輪夜班了
接下來的五年裡
他們的BMI和血脂狀況
仍然持續惡化
這證明了
夜班的工作
影響是長遠的
所以
輪班的人
越是需要運動量
最後
幫大家統整一下
輪班工作者
可以怎麼從生活改善呢
第一
避免睡前一小時高強度的運動
研究確實發現
晚上運動
比早上或下午
更容易干擾生理節律
那這是不是代表
晚上不能運動呢
也不是
因為這對大多數人的生活來說
根本做不到
但對我來說
只要晚上跑的強度超過 Zone 2
就可能會睡不好
所以我習慣早上6點起床
先跑步
再接送小孩
然後去診所看診
晚上幾乎不跑高強度
但也有人能夠在傍晚六七點
跑高強度間歇
晚上一樣睡得很好
所以
我們可以把重點放在
盡量避免睡前一小時
做高強度訓練
第二
運動量比運動時機更重要
如果你的作息很亂
真的不能選時段
至少做到
規律運動
先確保有運動
再確保運動量達標
最後
才是思考
最佳運動時機
最後
避免睡前兩小時進食
減輕身體消化食物的負擔
越是輪班的人
越是需要運動量
它能把你被輪班、熬夜
壓力破壞的節律
慢慢修回來
如果你願意
就從今天開始
找到適合自己的 Zone 2 節奏
喜歡這支影片
記得按讚、訂閱、分享
給需要的朋友
我們下次見
掰掰